jacob i'm coming to you first with a
semi unrelated question because
i might have watched that short film you
directed and oh
really it was it was awesome it was fun
thank you so much is there anything
about the experience of making that
that's impacted your work as an actor
maybe making you
aware of more behind the scenes stuff
than you might have been before
um i've always wanted to um
get into directing um i was on this show
called kirby buckets
uh and for the longest time i just ran
around this little notebook
i was like 12 years old and i'll just go
up to every director that would come in
just ask them like okay like why'd you
set up this shot like why did you do
this and
i just wanted to be a sponge and absorb
as much information as i could so i
could
um try to then replicate that you know
and
do something else with with my friends
actually showa was there for that uh
short film he he
i wouldn't have been able to make that
without him uh he helped out so much and
hido the stunt coordinator for cobra kai
actually helped out a bunch too
so did janelle and ken and john and
gisette uh that's so awesome that you
watched it though
thank you so much i really appreciate
that you should be proud i can't wait to
see the next one
thank you thank you getting into some
specifics for miguel here
so what is it like for you as an actor
to readjust after
the injury sidelines him is there
anything new you learned about yourself
as an actor when you take out that
original physicality that you had in the
last seasons
yeah i learned that it's much harder to
stay awake when you're forced to close
your eyes for
so long i think there were many days
where i was like i'm about to fall
asleep
but i'm but i think it'll work um no but
but in all seriousness i think their the
challenges really just came with
uh getting into the headspace of someone
who
you know has such
like a karate play such a large
part in miguel's life and i think beca
having that taken away even if it's just
for a brief moment
is really scary for miguel and i think
it's something that
he everyone is kind of going through for
the first time you know
obviously nobody knows how to prepare
for this and miguel especially so
the journey of getting reconciling with
johnny figuring out where he stands with
you know his mom
you know seeing if he's going to walk
again i think all of that happening at
the same time can be a little bit
stressful but
but hopefully we can come out on the
other side and uh and be triumphant
you capture it very well jacob one of
the exciting things for you this season
is how many meaty scenes you get with
martin cove like some one-on-one heated
investigations and i was loving it
what does martin do for you as a scene
partner that really stood out to you
first of all love marty he's the man
when they first told me i was going to
have a bunch of scenes with him i was
stoked
uh marty he
walks around when he is in the ghee he
will walk around
as crease he keeps that energy and that
intensity up
all the time so i think just like being
his scene partner
that constantly being there just really
helps and because i mean he is he's the
dominant force in almost
every single scene he's in you know and
especially a lot of my scenes i'm coming
up as as his student
you know up to him questioning some of
the things he's talking about and
you know there's so much you can learn
from the guy he is such a great actor
and he's
you know done it all seen it all and um
i just love working with that guy
huge congratulations on the new uh
season you guys thank you so much for
your time tonight
yeah thank you so much